[Music]
Christian
good evening
welcome welcome to the table my name is
James pronouns he and him and whether
you're here tonight in person or online
we're glad you're here with us we'll
start off with a couple of announcements
our welcome to the table class uh if
you're new to the table and want to
learn more about who we are and what it
may look like to join the community we
would love for you to attend our welcome
to the table class next Sunday August
25th from 3: to 4:30 p.m. sign in using
the QR code Center peace Conference
October 24th through the 26 at Willshire
Baptist Church in Dallas Center peace is
a fully affirming Christ centered
organization that provides a place to
belong and nurtures the faith of lgbtq
plus folks and allies find out more and
register using the QR code on the
screens now we exit the kingdom of noise
hurry and
productivity now we enter the kingdom of
Silence
Stillness and
simplicity Sacred
Space a place for
worship prayer and
adoration a place to behold Christ
revelation of God heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you to mend your heart
may we all come
[Music]
home thank you if you guys want to stand
with us we're gonna start off with good
God tonight Jenny Lee's gonna lead us
and um before we do that song I just
wanted to read this
passage thank
you
sorry the mic sharing was a little last
[Music]
minute this is out of Psalm
86 it says for you are forgiving and
good oh Lord abounding in love to all
who call to you hear my prayer oh Lord
listen to My Cry for mercy in the day of
my trouble I will call to you for you
will answer me and I love The Confidence
from David as he's writing that that in
our days of trouble that we can trust
that he is good that he is forgiving
that he is full of mercy and when we
call to him he will answer us so let's
approach this set tonight as we go into
this music and sing these lyrics
together let's try to believe in our
hearts that God is hearing our cries and
that he is with us
[Music]
Be Still My Soul Be Still My Soul be
still and know my God is
here be still my soul Be Still My Soul
be still and know my God is here all
that I need to know is this you are a
good good God maker of heaven calls me
you are a good God and your heart beats
in my chest you are a good God all that
I have to do is rest you are a good
[Music]
I won't be afraid I won't be afraid I
won't be afraid my God is
here he will make a way he will make a
way he will make way my God is here and
all that I need to know is this you are
a good god maker of heaven calls me you
are a good good God and your heart beats
in my chest you are a good God all that
I have to do is rest you are a good
[Music]
God you gave me your eyes you gave me
your heart your spirit flows through my
veins you gave me your eyes gave me your
heart your spirit flows through my veins
you gave me your eyes you gave me your
you gave me your right you gave me your
heart your spirit flows through my veins
you gave me your right you gave me a
heart you had a plan right from the
start I know who I am I know who you are
you are a good God all that I need to
know is this
the maker of heaven calls me
his all that I need to know this things
you are a good god maker of heaven calls
with you are a good God and your heart
in my
chair good God all that I have to do you
are a
good you are a good God you are a good
God you are a good God you are a good
[Music]
God all right I'm going to dismiss our
kids to their classrooms
now I love
it thank you kids ministry team for
loving on those kiddos we're so grateful
for you
[Music]
guys and we're going to transition into
the prayers of the people um most of you
know how this goes but if you are here
for the first time I just want to
welcome you to read along with us on the
screens um the parts in red we all say
together and then there will be a break
in the middle of the prayer for you to
um speak out a name or a situation
that's on your heart
and then um we'll close the prayer
together at the
end for this city of saxi Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
you for the names and the moments that
we have spoken aloud and for those that
we have kept in our hearts we pray to
you that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence amen
[Music]
the mighty one the
Lord calls to all the Earth for a heart
that he can find to the place it makes
its bed he calls his
people and we will listen he will not
keep silent until we feel the fire
again oh until we feel the fire
[Music]
again a thanful heart prepares the way
for you my
die a thankful heart prepares the way
for you my God seeing come fall on us
come fall on us we fall on you with
grateful
heart be are rym come fall on us we fall
on you the thanful heart will be our
soul
[Music]
the mighty one the Lord he calls to all
the Earth for a heart that would bow
down for a head that he could lift with
eyes of
Mercy a burning passion he will not keep
silent until we feel the fire
again oh until we feel feel the fire
[Music]
again a Greatful heart prepares the way
for you my
God a thankful heart prepares the way
God come for come fall on us we fall on
you the thankful
heart be our R come all on us we fall on
heart be our song sing it again come
fall on us we fall on you a thankful
heart will be are with come fall on us
we fall on you the painful
heart sing that one more
time come fall on us we fall on you a
thanful
heart will be our
rhythm come fall on us we fall on you a
thanful
heart will be our soul
[Music]
sing This Together God I Look to
You God I look to
you I won't be overwhelmed
give me
Vision to see things like you do God I
look to you you're where my help comes
from give me
wisom to know just what to do yeah
we're going to sing that again
together God I love to you I won't be
overwhelmed give me
Vision to see things like you do God I
look to you you where my help comes
from give me
wisdom to know just one
[Music]
do and I will love you and I will love
you Lord my
strength I will love you Lord my
shield and I will love you Lord my RO
forever all my days I will
love sing hallelujah
hallelu our god
reigns
hallelu Our God
Reign Hallelujah
our god reigns forever oh my gra
[Applause]
Hallelujah sing that together hallelujah
hallelujah our
god
Hallelujah Lord
God
hallelujah our god reigns forever my
days
hallelujah
oh
oh forever all my Hallelujah
[Music]
and I will Love You Lord my
strength and I will love you Lord my
shield and I will love you Lord my rock
forever all my days I will love you God
[Music]
yes
God we love
you thank you
God that
even in the struggle even
in pain or Darkness
God there is still
love there is still your
light there is still your goodness
surrounding us carrying us
through God help us to have grateful
[Music]
Hearts help us to find
you in the midst of whatever we are
going through God help us to look and
keep our eyes on
you to keep following in your
ways a forgiveness
and
hope God keep doing your work in our
lives keep changing us for the
better and we trust you and we love you
it's in your name we pray these things
amen would you guys just say hello to
the people around you before Brett gets
us started on our
message sticky
well Grace and peace it's uh it's good
to be with you all and to welcome you
into this space my name is Brett
pronouns he him and uh yeah it's just a
joy a joy to be with you um and that
includes those join us online love
youall Lots and anyone here tonight who
is new um maybe this your first time or
just first time in a long time we're
really really glad that you're here so
um we are in a series right now titled
The Parables of Jesus and uh Parables of
course are these kind of short stories
that Jesus would use as a kind of a
method of you know teaching and uh
something that people often kind of
perceive as the maybe like the weakness
of Parables uh I think is actually their
strength so the kind of perceived
weakness is that uh they they can be
well being stories without often
interpretation sometimes he offers a
little interpretation at the end
sometimes not so they can be kind of
open-ended you know and so you can often
read a parable and be left kind of
wondering
like what was that you know what is what
does this mean uh but I think that's
that's where actually that's kind of a I
think it's a strength uh a little bit
like a work of art say right where you
come to a painting or song or something
and um it can mean something different
to you through the years it it
speaks to you even in different seasons
of life um and in fact even where Jesus
offers an interpretation I still think
there's kind of a a depth Dimension to
it um I think for example I think it was
week one of this series where we talked
about the parable of the sewer and the
seed and such you know and the the
various types of soil and you that's an
example where like Jesus offers an
interpretation and yet as we
unpacked like you know but but what but
still it kind of begs the question yeah
but what does that mean you know what
okay so the the seed is the word of God
but what exactly is like the word of God
or the word of the Kingdom what exactly
is the kingdom of heaven or right you
can see where you're sort of this is the
nature of words though right words are
you
only kind of comine words with other
words so in essence you can kind of
always be you know saying what does that
mean and then you offer more words like
yeah but what does that mean you offer
more words like what is that right so in
other words we kind of have to start to
pick up um on The Parables sort of what
they're pointing to and a kind of lived
um experience kind of way and communally
right you you kind of read the
interpretations and how others have been
impacted by The Parables what God's
spoken to them through it and we kind of
you know come to discern Through The
Years um it sinks in more you know what
does this mean so in other words I don't
think parables are something we should
throw up our hands and be like they're
just unknowable you know who can
understand these things uh instead Like
Richard or says mystery is it doesn't
mean something just unknowable but
endlessly knowable right and that's what
a parable is it's it's it's not
unknowable or just confusing or weird
it's it's kind of endlessly um deep and
profound and so um with that in mind the
title of my message tonight is the
parable of the wedding
Feast so uh this one I would say is
maybe one of the less well-known
Parables you know in a lot of series on
Parables this one doesn't make the cut
but um I wanted to to get into it so we
find the reading the Gospel of Luke
chapter 14 beginning in verse one and
and then we'll kind of quickly skip down
to verse 7 uh one just provides kind of
some context so it says one Sabbath
right so this would be in the Jewish
tradition a Saturday the day of rest
when Jesus went to eat in the house of a
prominent Pharisee he was being
carefully
watched when he noticed how the guests
picked the places of honor at the table
he told them this Parable when someone
invites you to a wedding Feast do not
take the place of honor for a person
more distinguished than you may have
been invited if so the host who invited
both of you will come and say to you
give this person your seat
then humiliated you will have to take
the least important place but when you
are invited take
what the lowest place so that when your
host comes he will say to you friend
move up to a better place then you will
be honored in the presence of all the
other guests for all those who exalt
themselves will be humbled and those who
humble themselves
will be
exalted so let's let's start by talking
a little bit about uh first century
Judaism and like eating practices and
such we'll do a little a little history
so in short uh they didn't eat around
tables like sitting on chairs around
tables like we do um instead they they
had these um this is kind of yeah you
can see the image kind of it was like
these couches or cushions that kind of
reclined and then they would set up
tables kind of there along kind of the
edge and so you would kind of recline
there usually on your left right because
most people are right-handed sorry if
you're left-handed this is a really
rough seating arrangement but it's kind
of how it went so they recline on their
left so everyone's on the left able to
kind of GRA eat food you know and such
do everything with their right right
hand uh
so now here's how it worked though
hierarchically um right in like sort of
Western Society often kind of the leader
or the host or something will sit kind
of at the head of the table we call you
know they're kind of there at the end
where they have sort of a view of
everyone um so this was sort of similar
in that if there were two tables uh then
you had one kind of cushion slash
attached to the table that was
considered like the the higher or the
better it wasn't necessarily physically
higher but it was sort of considered you
know it was like the the elevated one um
and this is where if you were either the
host or just the most prominent person
so maybe if you invited you were the
host you invited someone you know really
socially Superior whatever in hierarchy
well then they would be the you know um
so wherever they were that was the sort
of the best table right then the the
other table of course the second that
would be sort of secondary or lesser now
it says this was a prominent Pharisees
home so it's likely there were three
tables so in that case they did like
this image shows a kind of U type
structure so in this case the host would
be right there at that Center table
right in the middle of the center table
uh from there it was a kind of track and
field setup right if you some of you
were just watching the Olympics a few
weeks back so you you got kind of the
fastest person there in the middle and
then from there it's like the closer you
are to that the better you know Lane's
one and eight not so good you know maybe
I had a rough prelim so so in this case
the host was there in the middle then
the the second best person was kind of
there to their left the Third Kind of to
their right the forth to the farth right
and you can kind of see where it sort of
went back and forth so that the further
you were from the center right the the
the Lesser um your social
status
so right you can see what sort of
happened in the story as uh in the
parable as each person entered um or I
should say not so much in the parable
what Jesus observed in real life you
know as they came in was likely each
Pharisee each religious person was doing
what they were automatically def
faulting to the next best place right
they were kind of assuming so the host
is there someone walks in they're like
oh well I am of course the second most
important person here so they took the
spot of the second the third person
walks in well makes sense I'm really the
third most important right and they kind
of just filed in uh and took always the
best seats right or the best um kind of
positions at the at the table um though
you know I should say perhaps I'm being
a little harsh because
they well I think most kind of cultures
in that area were what's known as honor
shame cultures uh
meaning you know the pursuit of kind of
social acknowledgement and honor was uh
and the kind of avoidance of public
shame was a huge deal like whatever
you're imagining ramp it up times 10 you
know like that's like to even I mean of
course no one wants to be embarrassed
like any culture at any time but it's we
just as Americans and kind of westerners
we can't really appreciate this partly
because of our individualism so you know
we're just I'm just me and you know um
if if someone in my family does
something that's like shameful it's not
you know it doesn't really cling to me
in some way uh not so in this culture
right if your sibling did something or
your community even your town engaged in
an act even if you didn't do the thing
it's like oh it it it kind of it uh
shame you might say clung to people so
because of this uh they were
incredibly sensitive to these kind of
issues of honor and shame so in other
words I say maybe I'm being too harsh
it's possible that they walked in and
they actually maybe weren't so confident
in their position like oh I am of course
the second most important person I mean
maybe they were kind of like oh I'm not
sure but what were they trying to
avoid right the shame they didn't want
to lower them eles take the Lesser so
they end up taking the higher seats
so okay so what's Jesus doing here I I
think um I think sort of at at one level
this Parable it's a a kind of
practical social teaching about honor
shame Dynamics and you know how to not
get utterly humiliated in a social
situation in person Cy you know
Palestine in that area uh and perhaps in
a little bit pass agressive way I when I
was talking with someone this week about
the message and they read the passage
like GE it sounds like Jesus is being a
little passive aggressive here like let
me tell you a story you
know um so I think that kind of it
functions sort of at that level in a way
you know it kind of is just a practical
like hey have you considered maybe not
taking the best seat that way possibly
you get moved up instead of having that
humiliated situation where you get moved
down you okay so I think at one level
that's it it kind of functions as a
social teaching um but I do think
there's something more going on you
might say a a deeper teaching of sorts
and there's um we see hints of this kind
of sprinkled throughout the the text so
the the first thing is um I want you to
notice in verse
14 Jesus opens the parable by um using
this language of a wedding Feast it says
this when someone invites you to a
wedding feast
and I was thinking like why a wedding
Feast I mean it's notable right they're
not currently at a wedding that would
make a lot of sense like at a wedding
he's like hey next time you're at one of
these maybe don't do this you know um
but no they're just like having dinner
on the Sabbath at a religious person's
house but he says when you're at a
wedding Feast okay so kind of just you
know tuck that away keep that in mind um
then we read there well the passage we
read ended in verse 11 but actually the
the parable or the story kind of goes on
in a way or at least the teaching part
of it does uh Jesus has some words not
only for the guests but actually for the
host as well so verse 12 then Jesus said
to his host when you give a lunch in or
a dinner don't invite your friends your
brothers or sisters your relatives your
Rich neighbors if you do well they may
invite you back and so you'll be repaid
but actually when you give a banquet
invite the poor the crippled the lame
the blond mind and you will be blessed
although they cannot repay you you will
be
repaid at the resurrection of the
righteous that's the key phrase the
resurrection of the righteous so we've
got wedding Feast language sort of oddly
thrown in there and then we've got this
language of the resurrection of the
righteous uh and then finally I want to
return to Jesus closing words at least
in the first part um verse 11 right
where he says all those
who exalt themselves will be humbled and
those who humble themselves will be
exalted uh that's if you're familiar
with the teachings of Jesus you know
this kind of theme in language is like
really familiar you know the the first
shall be last and the last you know
shall be first or uh the the servant
among you shall be what the greatest of
all you know it's like uh there's
there's this these kind of uh words that
always these phrase these turns of
phrase that are always about this um
this kind of
reversal um now so when we read it here
we might kind of ask the question like
well when does Jesus expect this to
happen right the the exalted will be
humbled and the humbled exalted and you
might think just like when I mean
presumably as Jesus is telling the story
the Pharisees who came in first they're
just happily laying there chomping away
you know so I don't think it's like just
get ready host anytime you're going to
tell you know I I know and and we know I
mean you look at this in this life in
this world a lot of times those who
exalt themselves are just exalted and
you know like well it's how it goes I
mean sometimes there's that you know uh
but often not and and a lot of times the
lowly the all these folks he mentioned
the lame the blind the crippled the you
know those on the margins and the edges
just sort of go through life sort of
push to the edges and it's like well
okay Jesus when's that when's that thing
happening you know um so what is Jesus
getting at with all this this reference
the wedding Feast resurrection of the
righteous exaltation of the The Humble I
think I Think Jesus is um not just
thinking of this life in this world I
think um he's thinking of the life to
come uh there's in some places there's
an event um that's called The Wedding
Feast of the lamb and that's the
language of like Revelation and and
Jesus is always talking about this sort
of this banquet this party like that's
in a lot of his Parables there's and and
certain ones really hint at a party to
come what I'll call um the great party
that is to come at the end of all
things and um many of The Parables and
such kind of hint to this like great
party that is to come and uh it's it's
interesting party because like on the
one hand sort of everyone's like
invited uh but not everyone is equally
honored
um in in fact like for example there's
you know a lot of the expect the people
you would expect are there like the rich
and the religious folks and such uh but
as the parable kind of alludes to Jesus
expects other people there as well
people that we might be surprised at the
the poor the suffering
you know Etc and it's a unique party
though not only because of who is there
but also because this is where the great
reversal
occurs in other words um right everyone
is invited but as I said not everyone's
equally honored and so all those who in
this life kind of elbowed their way to
the front of every line
all those who in this world stepped on
others to get where they were going all
those who exalted themselves and used
whatever power they could get to exalt
themselves
further Jesus says those folks are in
for a massive surprise because they
might
think I'm great I like I am winning at
life and so there therefore in the life
to come I will be winning
there
no no because what
happens it's the great
reversal those who were
marginalized edged
out fired
unjustly pushed out of Social
Circles shamed
silenced it's
those who Jesus says at the end of all
things you're going to be
recognized
elevated
honored
seen it's the great
reversal it's a
tremendous I think Pro promise in a lot
of ways a promise to set some things
right that at least in this world often
just aren't right just not
right there's a a great example of this
in uh a series of
books that at least the Christian
circles I used to be in they really
hated these books at least when they
first came out they seemed more broadly
accepted later um referring of course to
to JK Rowling's Harry Potter series I
remember when this first came out oh my
goodness the hubub you know I can just
say I think I was maybe high school or I
was not allowed to read those books you
know witchcraft whatever um and I I I
didn't really you know I didn't get into
them then it was only like I don't know
maybe five years ago I went back and
read them and uh I was like oh my gosh
these are so
Christian uh and it's actually because
of this idea like if there's like one
major theme in Harry po Potter and sorry
there will be spoilers coming just I
don't know if you're you had like 20
years I don't know what to tell you know
um like this is like a major theme in
that Series right the lowly the orphaned
the abused the young you know I mean and
so the powerless are what raised up
exalted empowered you know and then all
those who in this life in world had all
the power and all the money and all the
influence and all the connection and
right and used it to bad ends right what
happens to them it's
like BR low BR L you see this I say the
spoiler this is the big spoiler at the
end like the last book um it's in the
picture the image of the character
Voldemort right who of course is like
the epitome I mean he who must not be
named you know is he's the worst for
those who haven't read it or engag the
movies or whatever he's the wor He's the
bad guy and and he is like he's the
epitome the picture of just sheer power
power uh whatever he wanted he got you
know and if you didn't give it to him
he'll just kill you you know it's like
that that was kind of he just un
unbelievably
violent vile just like the just the
worst but for so much of his life he
just thrived you know like doing great
uh until some bad things happened but
then he made a comeback he was terrible
and you know uh and just the worst right
but then you I love how Jake around how
she set this up because you get this
Glimpse it's kind of a weird thing like
you don't know is Harry like is he like
seen just kind of a vision is he
hallucinating is he like really in the
life to come it's all sort of vague you
know and kind of how in our secular age
it kind of has to be but he gets this
image of the life to come where
Voldemort's
defeated and uh I mean it's unbelievable
because it's there that you see uh
Voldemort is kind of revealing he for
the
absolute inner shambles that he is that
that in essence is at a kind of a deeper
level at a soul level um I mean it's
what Jesus said he traded for the world
and lost his soul so in the life to come
he's literally like in the corner this
kind of
wheezing weak Soul just this this like
just frail form barely hanging on to
life because what happened I it's the
great reversal at the end at the end of
all
things and I think it's it's interesting
there it's not so much that I think God
you know cast Voldemort to the pits of
hell and he's tortured forever you know
no no it's more like it's more like an
an
unveiling a revelation like this is who
he's always
been I think in the same way at the end
of all things there will be a great
party and it will reveal who we have
been all our
lives which is a sobering it's a
sobering
thought really sobering I hope I'm not
stirring up too much spiritual anxiety
for you oh gosh you know um because I do
think God is love you know there's
compassion there's Grace but there's a
reckoning of sorts you know
so what does this mean for us here and
now you know I think um I think at the
very least I think it's it's an
invitation to maybe change what we're
aiming for in life you know like it's
it's just so easy I think to get swept
up with the culture because the culture
certainly doesn't live as though this is
true you know like oh yes the humble
shall be on that day exalted you know
it's like whatever like we're everyone
of course is just pursuing you know
whatever fame money whatever they can
get and it's just easy to slip into that
but I I think the invitation for us is
to um is to live differently it's to
begin to reorient our lives now so so
let's not seek the the highest places
like let's not pursue with our whole
being uh more money and power and
whatever Fame we can grasp like if if
some of those things come so be it fine
you know what I mean I'm not I'm not
saying like it's a s if you got a
promotion this year that's a sin you
know it's not my point it's it's it's
more like this the seeking the you know
I mean that grasping kind of craving um
thing in us so let's begin to let these
things go let's instead as we talked
about last week pursue the treasure
hidden in the field the pearl of great
price let's pursue deepest Union with
god let's allow the spirit to cultivate
those virtues within us
compassion Mercy that a major theme of
our Parable next
week great love humility
forgiveness
Grace
peacemaking like let's allow the spirit
to do that in us and then let's be sent
out into the world to
serve to
serve to be of use to others be of use
to God like that's that's the heart and
then on that day
who you've been often in secret you know
because those aren't things that get
headlines so much like man of you know
man or woman of tremendous forgiveness
lives in sexy Texas you know the
headlines yell you know
like uh but in that day it it will it
will be revealed yeah in the name of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
amen so as we uh as we come to the table
of the Lord tonight as we take in
consume the body of Christ the blood of
Christ we get a little a little
foretaste of that that banquet to come
little little taste of heaven
and In This Moment Christ is the
host and we you are the invited guests
so come forward with that with that
confidence
that uh maybe you're feeling pretty
edged out right now in the world in
whatever kind of social spheres you're
in or whatever life looks like for you
just know uh here you are wanted and
welcome at this table so the way we'll
go about this is we'll um start here at
the front and we'll just form one line
right down the middle uh we practice
what's called an Open Table meaning if
you're here tonight and you want to
participate then you are you're welcome
to do that even if you maybe don't you
know understand all the Theology of
exactly what communion is about about
and such uh but you're if you if there
something in you wants to connect with
the Risen Christ then you're you're
welcome to to do that um you should know
the red is wine the white is grape juice
and then finally you're you're um just
go ahead and partake however and
whenever you'd like some folks like to
come and kneel here at the front others
take it immediately others like to
return to their seats have a moment um
but no one will lead you through the
exact you know taking of the elements
you just just do that um on your own as
you feel l so this is the table of the
church but of the
Lord and it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more so
God you who have much
Faith you who have little you who have
been here often and you who have not
been here long you who have tried to
follow and you
failed come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
[Applause]
come
all come all
shamed come all wealthy come receive it
to the table come
today come come all
broken come all
needy come all poor and come all
slaves come all rulers come be
seed come all siners Come All Saints
come to the
table from near and
far come come from the
Shadows come out of the
dark there's room at the
table we saved you
see come to the
[Music]
bqu come join in the feast
every race and every
nation from all reels come all
G from the
fres come to
Jesus to a table full of
grace to the table come and stay come to
the table
come eat and
drink there's no
inner come with the
King re at the
table come let down your
God you're never a stranger
just come as you
are come
behold come be
love come
accept
it come now
come come behold
come be
Lov come be
[Music]
sa come now
come come
behold come be
love come accepted
come now
come prepare is the
[Music]
table we're ready
to the party is
W his for still
[Music]
defe the Harvest is
ready go kill every
SE go live out the
M as a kingdom of
[Music]
priest go live out the
M as a kingdom of PRI
[Music]
thank you so much for joining us this
evening if you are new we would love for
you to fill out a card at the table on
your way out or just scan the QR code on
the screens to fill out the online
visitor card that will allow us to
follow up with you answer questions you
might have and say thank you for
visiting if you are need a prayer a hug
or just general support come find me
after the service I would love to be
there for you however I can and as
always generosity is a key aspect of a
life of adoration and worship to give
financially you can scan the QR code or
visit the TBL tx.org
all right let me send you into your week
with this blessing you can hold out your
hands in a posture to receive simply
open your heart to these
[Music]
words you are a child of
God you are a child of God this is true
on your best day and this is true on
your worst day so go into your week
ahead with it's yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you are and go filled
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with be blessed and we hope
to see you here again next Sunday
[Music]
prepared is the
table we're ready
to the party is
way there's more still to feel
the Harvest is
ready go fill
every go live out the
Miss as the kingdom of
[Applause]
PR go live out the
Miss is a kingdom of PR
J
[Music]